these have really come in handy
[Laughter]
ed sheeran is cutting courtney cox zero
slack when it comes to his hilarious
pranks
it was good very very fun on monday the
singer made an appearance on the late
late show with james corden
dishing on his friendship with the
friends star and this prank he routinely
pulls on her
using this um unique accessory
she has this alexa thing
in her house and she goes hey this isn't
this wonderful this is my alexa i can
just
order whatever on this so she walks out
the room and do you know what a [ __ ]
mask is
you know like an an s m leather [ __ ]
mask so she walks out the room
i'm aware and i go i go alexa order me a
[ __ ] mask
ed reveals that it was courtney's
assistant who opened up the gift in
front of her
leaving her shocked courtney comes up
and she's like
where did this come from anyway she
found out the story and then
now every time i go back there i order
her another [ __ ] mask and she has maybe
like
12 and then i i hide them in people's
bedrooms so
they'll go in a drawer and they'll just
find this like leather snm mask
and in honor of ed's 30th birthday
courtney sent the singer a video
rocking what she now calls her most
protective coved mask
and happy birthday and now we're in this
pandemic and here i am on set and uh
courtney we need your upset please i
just want to say thank you so much for
all the protection these have really
come in handy
[Laughter]
and to cordon surprise ed purchased the
talk show host his very own mask
too i did buy you one it's got an extra
it's got an extra padlock
[Laughter]
come on let's see you in it mate come on
i've got to be honest
it starts as a joke but the more you buy
for people it starts to
i feel absolutely incredible
gag gifts aside ed also opened up about
his recent weight loss which he largely
credits to fatherhood the singer
officially became a dad to a baby girl
lyra in september i feel like
um my lifestyle shift has changed
instead of going to bed at six i'm
getting up at four
my days are structured i'm i'm healthier
than i've ever been i'm exercising every
day
the superstar has also been laser
focused on his music
including his new single bad habits
[Music]
conversations
[Music]
and although we don't know what his
awaited fit studio album will have in
store
fans suspect we may be getting a collab
with his old pal courtney
after teasing this video on instagram
earlier this month
if you need further proof that ed and
court are truly fantastic at working
together
well here's them doing the routine you
know the one courtney's character monica
on friends did with her on-screen
brother
ross
[Music]
while we cross our fingers for courtney
cox collab it's no secret that ed has
collaborated with many superstars over
the years
in 2014 the grammy winner opened up to
et about how he approaches working with
musicians he admires
to be honest all the collaborations that
i've had have come through chance
experiences with them approaching me
because i i don't view anyone to be like
oh i could collaborate with them because
you never
you never think that so the rick rubins
of the worlds and the pharrells and
elton john's they've all kind of come in
and being like oh we like what you do
can we can we do this
rather than me approaching them because
i feel it would be a bit arrogant to
just assume someone wants to work with
you so
i'd prefer to just live my life waiting
for people to come to me i guess because
you
get less let down a lot less i'm
surprised a lot more
[Music]